[Music]
okay so here's the thing i have been
obsessively googling you let me just
start with i'm terrified of this
situation this is my nightmare okay your
name came up about doing the podcast and
i was like oh my god we love her we love
her and i just assume you'd say no or
cancel yeah i didn't see it on my
calendar until yesterday
so and that's why i was like dan what do
i do it's tomorrow yeah so what do you
think you want to cancel you can still
cancel it's
i don't think i knew how different your
essence was from stevie's oh yeah that's
yes it's a nightmare like i go on a date
well i don't know and people like hey
people are rough with you no no they
expect me to be like stevie and then
they're like oh you're
nothing like stevia no it's like a
disappointment because i'm a lot and
stevie is like
that is wild because it's like and now
and then i had this whole new as i was
watching all your stuff this weekend and
listening to you on these podcasts i was
like oh this is such a
um
what night
nightmare this is a highly sensitive
person like me remember i was like oh
you're me yeah and this person is um
uh and then i started panicking because
i was like oh i thought i was gonna deal
with this like tough bitch that i know
that i pretend to be yeah you know what
i mean i know how to go into autopilot
and just go with my like defenses so i
text uh dan levy
uh
emily's here tomorrow to tomorrow i'm
scared oh
let me just raise your text
with dan levy
tan writes back why are you scared i'm
gonna see if i can sneak away you'll
love her she's wild and very sweet oh my
god i can't believe dan did not say that
about me
i ca that's very weird i'm surprised
that he said that and then i wrote i am
a true fan of her work as an actor
separate text can't believe he didn't
make any jokes legitimately i wrote i am
more worried i'm gonna like comma get
nervous and cause damage by accident
and then dan wrote back
good content that is good content
ah i wrote dan last night um i just
realized my whitney cummings podcast is
tomorrow i don't know what to talk about
does she mean she can be mean to me and
he goes lol no
she's a fan which was very nice but uh
but then i texted gigi gorgeous who i
saw was on your podcast and i'm like hey
i'm going on whitney cummings podcast
tomorrow do you have any tips i'm scared
because i don't know her at all and so
do you have any insights words of wisdom
words of warning exclamation mark
exclamation point
then i texted um sarah gilbert she says
and sarah gilbert was like i don't know
i've never been on her podcast i'm like
don't you work together she's like
she's always been sweet to me you strike
me as someone that just has a giant
heart and i started going oh my god i'm
so scared because she's that you were
going to be mean
not mean i know that i can be rough by
accident and i normally have people in
the podcast that i know well that know
who i am and where my heart is but
sometimes people tell me they're like oh
yeah this person on it was like a little
awkward there for a minute a little
uncomfortable and i'm like oh it was
like when i say like are we friends no
no
no i mean we're not
people like why are you putting people
in the spot like it makes them
uncomfortable and i'm like oh i didn't
even know that's what i was doing i was
kind of just trying to get like oh i
like that sometimes i'm an accident i'm
like a bully by accident
oh and i don't want to do that with you
but i so i've watched your entire avra
and um i
i
was
scared you were gonna be mean then when
i watched everything because i and your
podcast and everything
you're not like that at all you're not a
bully you're actually like
normal
oh that's that's true that was the
meanest thing you've ever said to me
did you just call me fat what's
happening did you just call me healthy
i'm sorry i look healthy whoa so i'm
bored
no but like in the podcast you're having
a conversation and it doesn't feel i
guess what to me that meant it doesn't
feel like you have an agenda which i
really liked it doesn't feel like you're
trying to like
not in the slightest yeah i think for me
i just i'm i'm so fascinated by you and
um i just i want to
i've just been in a panic about you and
i wrote down specific questions i i have
a couple i'm gonna go back and forth
this is gonna be a wild one
uh
introducing beam dream beam is the
world's most innovative functional
wellness brand with unique products for
everything from sleep to recovery it
contains natural sleep promoting premium
ingredients triple lab tested no thc no
no no and you wake up refreshed 98 of
people surveyed fall asleep faster when
taking beam dream and 99 of people
experience better sleep quality and if
you don't love it get your money back
guaranteed but you will you nerd again
twenty dollars off when you go to
bmorganix slash gfy and use the code gfy
at checkout don't be dumb that's b e
beam organics.com gfy and use code gfy
for 20 off take beam for a sweet dream
i can't fall asleep without flicking my
beam
i'm calling hr like i flick it into the
mug oh into the mug emily how dare you
that's it okay emily that's not a
vibrator that is that is what it's a
frother that is a frother but after
after you flick your beam then you frost
it wait you froth your beard what is
that it's a frother
oh yeah that's what i use it for i use
it to curl my hair this morning oh fuck
i also might do this a lot because i
just a lot of medication it gives me dry
mouth oh my god i'm obsessed with you
but it's really nitro intro okay emily
hampshire and i are the same person
wait so you i mean it's pretty i've used
a lot of it i thought i was the only
person that carried this around the
biotene dry mouth moisturizing the gel
the mouth moisture the mouth lube you
know what else i do so i
i'm sort of notorious for putting grape
seed oil on my face all the time like to
obviously
combat aging
um i'm fine with that but also i'm
fighting it tooth and nail but
i also put it in my mouth ew mmm
grapeseed oil if you before you go to
bed because my mouth gets dry in the
middle of the night right yeah i just
put grapeseed oil on my teeth my gums in
my mouth no one else does this no olive
oil i mean
but if you have a dry mouth situation
now i think i might try it yeah because
but when you're on the road yeah like i
always am then you get
you get dry mouth in a random hyatt in
toledo you're not finding a biotin spray
no no
so i'll just take a swig of olive oil
that's so
and it stays and you wake up the next
morning your mouth
no one
like no one's nailed moisturizing the
mouth yet no they haven't actually but
wait when you say putting the olive oil
that sounds like those people who do
that oil pulling have you heard of that
you go like you swished no one's heard
of that
keep going well but that's basically i
wanted somebody else to have heard of it
because that's all i know is that they
switch and it just sounds disgusting
like oil pulling it's an alternative
medical practice in which an edible oil
is swished around in the mouth for a
period of time and then spat out similar
to mouthwash and practitioners of oil
pulling claim it is capable of improving
oil i'm sorry improving oral
improving oral and whole body health
that is like um to me
on the level of premium sunning butthole
sunning that's like it's there's easier
ways to do it and if you're
swishing around oil in your mouth and
you're oil pulling and telling me about
it you're just trying to be better than
me like i just you have too much time on
your hands um
but wait the the
perennium stunning i thought people
wanted to bleach it now it's getting it
tanned well here's the thing
i just i guess keep up
oh wow
like i feel like i'm behind on
everything it was literally in
figurative things
so
yes i my first anal bleaching experience
happened in las vegas wait you did it
well
unclear i can't see it i don't know will
someone tell me i paid to have my
asshole bleach i would like to bend over
i swear to make sure that thing got
bleed well here's the thing if you're
gonna bleach your butthole you also have
to laser it off because if you have a
bleach butthole with brown hairs coming
out it's not gonna there's like they
should do like a one-two punch situation
where it's like you get bleached and
waxed because if you bleach it but don't
wax it it's still gonna have a you know
yeah it's not gonna be as pink as you
would have imagined so i go to i'm in
vegas this is like 14 years ago
yeah probably and it's the first time
anyone ever reached out to me to give me
something for free no the first thing
you got for free no bleaching as like a
person who's on tv it was like hey like
would you like to come in for a free
thing like the first paid partnership i
ever had i just got a first paid
partnership for a vibrator
they said we're emily fans and we'd like
to send you a video is meant for me
[Laughter]
i feel like that's a step up from
bleaching
you know i mean that's a step below
kimchi
it's unclear
i have to know more about this vibration
um so
i go and they're like you're in town
dude and i like feel famous like i'm
like i've made it
your bubbles here your but your
butthole's in vegas we have a butthole
bleaching company and we'll have you i'm
like the celebrity at the butthole
bleaching place
so like i'm like okay this is my demo
and i go first of all it's like 45
minutes outside vegas red flag
to get the free butthole bleaching i
have to like get a cab
that cost me like a hundred and thirty
dollars they didn't send you there you
had to
yeah they think i like car service they
think i'm fake because they think you're
famous i mean then here's the thing as
in you know more than anyone as an actor
you can be famous and poor oh oh i love
you yes
i get these
dms that it's my fault for looking
through the alt dm account but it's like
since you're rich can you help me on
this thing i'm like i did a show in in
canada with canadian dollars which is
equivalent to seashells you did a play
in canada
for
five years five six years in six years
and then netflix picked it up yes
and then everything you thought it was
charming yeah
because there's a musical in it because
it costs nothing yeah well you know the
only reason it went on for six years is
because we did it in canada and with the
cbc because
i know for a fact that well first of all
dan went to sell it like tried to get an
american network for the show at the
beginning no one wanted it like no one
wanted shit's creek and then canada did
it our you know government-funded
programming and so
they let us keep going when
we weren't popular like
no one knew about the show until it was
over like they just forgot to cancel it
yeah
they were like wait a second you know
when you see something auto charging on
your credit card like a gym membership
and you're like too much to like it's
like the amount of time it would take me
to cancel the show it would probably
cost more just like okay yeah and it's
canada they were being nice i think
yeah
[Laughter]
but um but but i don't want to skip over
your asshole
so
um i really need to know the story look
not many people in hollywood
have yeah um
i get there and i realize i'm like oh no
there's no such thing as free
and so is is this woman taking a selfie
with my butthole i don't know what's
happening you know because there's
always some kind of barter system for it
right and so like what do i owe you now
so i get there
this woman she's lovely it's a system
okay okay remember like 15 years ago
everything was a system teeth whitening
system anal bleaching system it was a
system yes so this was the first of a
system
you're basically saying hey
i
i'm giving you the opportunity
to rub your own asshole
every day three times a day for the next
three months for free oh it's an at-home
system
this is that
this is feeling less free every
everything you said home system that you
had to get a really probably expensive
cab for because if it was far out
like so i had to drive here for you to
give me the lotion and put it on so that
to show me how to put it on i feel like
i could have figured out how to put
lotion on my asshole i feel like i need
to come here
for you to tell me where my asshole is
but i remember being in the like rural
vegas with this woman being like
okay you think i'm who's i'm the asshole
in the city
i just want a pink asshole you just want
like what is this rigmarole so i did and
then i found myself like three weeks
later three times a day i'm reapplying
this gel to my butthole and you have to
let it like dry so do you have to just
yeah i have a big ass so i'd have to
like hold it
well i would open my butt and then put
it on my asshole and then just you have
to just let it dry because it's blea the
idea is that it's slowly over three
months bleaches your asshole yeah and
then uh three times a day and i was like
if this woman just started a fake
business
and it's just like she's a genius cause
i three times a day i'm i'm bending over
like airing out my butthole putting gel
on my butt to bleach my asshole for whom
did you do a before though like a before
and after because i feel like i honestly
i've
never really
looked at my asshole if it needs
bleaching i'm very white i don't leave
the house so
i am
if your biggest problem with my asshole
is that it might have some stuff you
shouldn't be there you know what i'm
saying yeah like if you don't uh uh what
is it if you don't like me at my worst
you don't deserve me at my best yeah i
don't know if you don't like my asshole
it's brown you don't deserve it
i have been listening to
your new show okay okay beautiful liar
this is a uh audio
story narrative narrative podcast
podcasts are now huge people love it
they and i was listening to yours
because you were on let me i had never
listened to one before yeah and i was
like i have to listen to this emily's
and i
had so much fun because you know why
i was able to like cast it with my own
imagination i mean i've just had you as
the as the the voice in the community
yeah what our imagination can conjure is
so much more powerful than anything you
could ever really capture on
film whatever it is so it was like this
magical experience was like oh are we
back to like
radio stars i think so i actually
did radio dramas in canada whoa when i
was a kid with the people who did the
footsteps behind the fully artist
yeah yeah i'm obsessed if anyone is go
into a deep youtube hole on foley
artists oh it's amazing it's amazing
it's like it's asmr yeah we have
porn so i um
i've talked about this before on the
show but if you go into a foley artist
um like whenever i'm at warner brothers
or paramount i'm always like can i swing
by the fully artist like i'm such a fan
and you go into their these are the
people that make all the sounds for
westerns for murders for horrors and
like in order to uh get the sound of for
example in drive when
that amazing scene of ryan gosling like
gives her a kiss and then crushes the
guy's skull the way that they made the
sound for crushing a skull is they took
like a sugar glass and put it over
watermelon just to
be a
brain
being slashed into skull like just the
way they do it they think that up
they've got a thousand pair of boots and
and mud and dirt and like just their
office is just like a flea market full
of shit and they're just making sounds
i'm obsessed but that's also what i i
felt when i listened to this because you
know i'm sure well this happens to me a
lot where you do something and you don't
know if it's gonna be good or not you
think it's like i i thought
these scripts were so good
that i was like i i have to do this i
did it in my closet for no money i like
decked out my closet because it was
covered and um i just thought it was so
great but then when i heard it
i it really did blow my mind this is
it's a superhero origin story and like
you said you make up the people in your
head and so
you know we're always given what a super
hero female superhero should look like
and should be like and so you're
listening to this 16 year old kid and
whatever you look like and are like you
can project that into this person which
i thought well that's what i
did um because it it also just
lets you create your world yes
and i think also you
diversity and stuff like that how can i
tell you i i was like this is like the
solution to all these problems it's like
you know in my like
representation and you know how do we
cast this role and this person is
miscast and you can't hire this person
of color to play this person who doesn't
have the experience and it was like oh
my gosh these audio narrative podcasts
is like i can just imagine anyone i want
and i can build whatever world i want
and still like glean the same like
entertainment and lessons etc it was so
um i was like doing chores to it and i
was like i was so i was having the best
time with myself because i wasn't
distracted by
humans and editing and music and like
having to like watch a screen yeah it's
like i was like moving around the world
like in this world in your head it was
so fun it was like being on drugs
i haven't been on everything it does
feel like that though though like the
way it's also the sound design does feel
like
it's so it it takes you to another
place in an escapism way i think that
you know a lot of people um uh i know
are like getting super into anime like
younger people and maybe that's the same
thing because it's like animated
characters it's not actual human beings
that you can google and like find flaws
in and you see that they just broke up
with their girlfriend or had a kid and
it kind of like shatters the surreal uh
you know fantasy of it all yeah you know
so it's like it just i don't
do a lot of like fantasy stuff and it
was like it was but it was so nice to go
like this is the fantasy that like was
built by you and the writers but also i
got to participate too yeah you put your
brain into it as a control freak virgo i
got to cast it
[Music]
that's what i'm saying
now you see why i'm so weirded out by
you when's your birthday september 4th
okay i'm august 29th okay michael
jackson okay this has to be a good thing
oh no
i will not do this michael jackson
her people hurt people
okay not defending japan
[Applause]
i'm just saying michael jackson made
some bops and at some point we will get
into the fact that michael jackson also
abused animals
no
big time big time with cats i know do
not fuck with cats the elephants and the
chimps and yeah all that kind of stuff
yeah yeah it was bad so so to me
whenever anyone wants to bring the
michael jackson thing up it's like
like
if anyone's on the fence i'm like how
abusive he was to animals kind of tells
everyone everything they need to know we
didn't really circle back to the dry
mouth what do you attribute that to i
take a lot of medication that makes my
mouth is that one of those
side effects that's so wild really it's
a side effect that i never
thought would be like a debilitating
thing but it is it really is because
then if you don't deal with it you get
that smegma around your lips disgusting
oh it's my nightmare and then if you get
your hair and makeup done for something
and then you have this like you have
this hard
line of gooey schmergma and you're
talking to people and you get home and
you realize that you just have like this
disgusting yeah like gelatinous twizzler
mouth oh my god it's so gross i was
thinking that when i was watching your
stand up i was like you're talking this
whole time you didn't have any water you
didn't have any and i have to go host
this thing
next week and i'm just afraid of
getting drunk
we're taking a break to talk about the
shit you have to do to make sure you
don't die and to make sure your shit
emily
has
it seems like you've had no problems
with shitting lately
bullshitting
okay you guys emily finally got her
christmas gift from me and it has turned
her into a different person okay she got
a purse that she's kind of put in my
whole life her entire life and it's
she's a different person you know some
people listen to this too absolutely
you're just miming she's just mugging
into the camera for those only listening
she is wearing a purse in a way that
makes her look like a really chic
alcatraz person it's around my neck
she's wearing it around her neck like a
like a cow has a trough of food around
her neck so well i'll just laugh into my
celine bag
here's the thing i do feel like emily
you have been changing your eating
habits you guys know i have been taking
athletic greens
i've been doing this for years i mean i
heard about it on rogan ages ago and
here's the problem pills make me gag i
gag
i swear to god this morning i was
brushing my teeth and i puked in the
sink it like a little puke came up i
swear to god i was brushing like a back
left tooth and i literally was like and
a little puke came out it was just like
coffee and i turned around and alex was
just standing in the doorway and he was
like
he was like cartoon timing and he said
that i turned around like kristen wiig
doing ghillie
i literally was like sorry
so i cannot take pills there's like a
billion vitamins we need to take but the
only way i can do it is without athletic
greens tons of people take some kind of
multivitamin it's important to choose
one with high quality ingredients that
your body will actually absorb you're
investing in all in one nutritional
insurance right now it's time to reclaim
your health and arm your immune system
yeah if you're not taking care of your
body after what's gone on for the last
couple years i dan can't help you uh
daily nutrition is the most important
thing especially heading into the flu
and cold season is that still a thing
the flu in the cold i thought we
cancelled those okay one scoop and a cup
of water every day that's it no need for
a million different pills and
supplements to look out for your health
and it actually absorbs into your body a
lot of that other shit doesn't absorb
and it's weird to make it easy athletic
reads is going to give you a free
one-year supply of immune supporting
vitamin d
something emily doesn't get enough of
false i have my full this year
i'm good for two more years it's the end
2024
uh supply immune supporting vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase all you have to do is go
to athleticgreens.com
whitney even grace approves of it and
her generation doesn't like anything i
think's a good idea that's true atlanta
queens dot com slash whitney take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
and get your poop schedule
regular regular you know what i'm going
to carry in my new purse
i'm going to carry something for when i
need the perfect medium high
diet smoke delta 8 thc gummies dude
these are what we took when we were
writing the josh richards roast when he
was here chrissy uh crystal smith was
here and she was like where's the weed
where's the weed and i was like i don't
have any because weed i just like it
not no good like i just didn't but they
had sent this
and
she looked at the container and she
freaked out she knows she knew diet
smoke right away and i was like i don't
know i just i don't want to be tired
she's like i'm telling you right these
don't make you tired it's like the
perfect it made us focus more and made
us more energetic and i was like oh i
thought we'd made you stupid well it's
less potent than thc okay that's why
it's the same weed you know and love
just a little less strong
okay because to me i always go overboard
and i was like if i take edibles i'm
just going to become an idiot and she
was like trust me on this it made us
like sharper more energetic like it was
just like the perfect chill and you
can't rip a bong during
a roast writing session i mean that's
being filmed that's being filmed right
right yeah you can't read is legal now
when cbd isn't enough and bond grips are
too much
enjoy the smooth relaxing high of diet
smell no bongs it's just it's
the whole spitting on something and just
passing it those days are over right
yeah that's a great point it's really
bad
right now diet smoke is offering our
listeners an incredible discount when
you go to diet smoke.com and use promo
code whitney you'll get 20 off all of
their delta 8 thc gummies dietsmoke.com
promo code whitney to get 20
off that's a lot of percent that's
dietsmoke.com promo code whitney all
caps for 20 off diet smoke thc gummies
i'm telling you it's a game changer this
weekend i'm going to be in new haven
connecticut at the college street music
hall doing the yucks and the hahas and
the lols march 26th i'm gonna be in
albany in new york at the egg
april 1st i'm gonna be in austin texas
paramount theater april 2nd dallas texas
majestic theater april 3rd oh my god i
cannot stop burping i'll be in san
antonio the tobin center for the
performing arts i am a performing art uh
april 8th houston texas 713 music hall
april 9th new orleans
new orleans uh la the orpheum may 20th
tyson's corner the register winnie
coming.com don't make me read this i'm
getting a lot draw where do we land on
people we don't know having pimples and
like
can you pop them if you don't know them
oh
oh i
well
no
is it is it are you allowed to go out in
the world with just a white head and
talk to people
do i have a white house no i would tell
you okay but i'm saying i go on the
world and if i ask someone for
directions or something and then they
have like a white head or something i'm
like well now
i have to pop that oh my god all i think
about is seeing
blackheads like how dare you like
and then if someone has a wife or a
girlfriend and i'm like they didn't get
that
or i think she's so lucky
do you think she's just waiting for it
to cook i'm like oh yes
that's the thing where i waffle
sometimes between like sometimes i'm
like i'm totally over guys just into
girl and then sometimes i think but that
back blackhead situation
something i genuinely missed
plucking that ingrown hair on the
shoulder
my god and a port of whiner if you can
get someone with a fucking one that
refills i'm
so i had on my chest i had one of those
okay so it's basically like a pimple
that
it's like a it becomes a pit that keeps
refilling with pus yeah you're so lucky
and i didn't want to get it like handled
because i just the gratification
and i was like slather myself in oil and
just like try to make sure i put extra
there and like i would like you know
i would like not take a shower after
working out just to be like i feel like
i'm getting that
see i can't let myself with a magnifying
mirror
i can spend an entire day do you do your
all your pores okay so for me
usually when i'm on a plane i now have
boundaries for myself because
i which i can't have nails by the way
because if i have nails i will yeah i i
keep them short
so that i can do it without puncturing
my skin yes so that i can pop sets in a
way that is sanitary you take the i take
cleanup
go around
so hold on where's that
i need to know if you're i call i
consider myself a dermatologist this is
my okay so there's no
there's okay let's pretend let's don't
don't even look okay see if our
technique is the same
wait i'm not looking i'm not looking
okay we're both gonna wrap our fingers
to papa's in okay i'm not looking at you
you're not looking at me like normally
i double it well like this is pretty
thick
oh you're ready already i would hold on
but see i'm actually i also use lanterns
i'm actually over
[Laughter]
oh my god i use lances too for diabetes
here's the thing about the lance the
lance the lance guys i think were this
is like a it's like looks like a needle
almost like the top of a needle where
there's like a little hole in the top i
think it's sometimes when you push it
down and you're just able to get all the
pus out of all your pores but i think
for the the crevice
oh my god with dan i used to you know
those um oil absorbing things yeah
i would always be like please let me
kill it let me do it which is not as
satisfying but to get just to push it
down and see it okay i really okay so so
where are you at with your cuticles
oh
oh my god so i'm well first of all i eat
the skin around my hands so i'm army
hammer okay
too soon
hammer joke every january um
but
i love
i have a kit i have a tool kit and i
love like pushing them back and cutting
them all and doing all that but like i
don't take care of my like i'm just i
eat that part this is the most no one's
ever gonna talk to me i eat this
see that is really interesting okay
because i've got this one part of my
finger
that ever since i'm a kid i do this it
doesn't make a noise so don't panic but
i like mutilate it with another another
part of my thing and with two
finger
so i will let one of my thumbnails get
jagged so that i can dig into this one
more and then sometimes i will eat that
yes but hope it helped me with that
though with putting my hands in my mouth
i stuck because i would eat all so now i
just i've done it
off skin
okay no one's ever gonna which is fine i
like being alone
i don't think either of us are gonna
feel that
but no because i am actually at because
i think a lot of this is so based in the
way that we groom and the way we get
serotonin dopamine from squeezing zits
and ejecting infection from the body it
all makes sense and how yeah totally the
pruning etc but i am
at a little bit of a rock bottom with
the cutting my cuticles and the nip i
have kits everywhere i mean they're in
every room
and i now have a boundary for myself
that i won't cut my cuticles or nip them
unless i put the cuticle softener on
first
oh i will just be hemorrhaging edward
scissorhands i will just be fully
covered in black with my face if you
because and here's my biggest concern
is that do you ever do to your toes yes
i put them right up here so the only
reason i like
stretch is i'm like what if one day i'm
not able to reach my toes to be able to
cut all my ingrown toenails out don't
you have to i feel like that i have to
wait and let it cook like let it come
back to be able to do it but i do think
though i'm gonna i think i'm gonna have
to go to a podiatrist for this because i
think the more you dig it out
the more you're causing it to grow in do
you know what i'm saying i have an
ingrown thing remover oh so do i but
ingrown toenails you can get it lasered
so that it's cause because now my feet
like hurt okay yeah it hurts when they
grow in moon is like the worst pain it
is so painful and i will at midnight
when i'm anxious or i have a big day
tomorrow i will start digging into my
toes digging under my toenails every
little i will make my toes bleed and
then even the covers touching the top of
my toes like hurts yeah and i have
numbing cream i'll put on over it but i
also like when i've had an ingrown i
like the whole routine of like soaking
it like it hurts oh my god and then the
grass
i still fantasize about one time i had a
like because the key to like dead skin
under the toenails or tweezers like if
you can just grab that ingrown toenail
with a tweezer and pull one time i
pulled like all the skin out from inside
of like one of my toes where an ingrown
was and it wasn't an ingrown toenail it
was just dead skin i pulled it out so
like four years ago i still think about
it oh my god that is i think about
amazing what is like that what is that
i've i pulled out one thing and it was
fluff and it was disappointing it was
like sock fluff when i was like digging
digging in there and it was something oh
see that i mean that was just it was
disappointing there's something so
satisfying i guess just about like
removing dead skin from the body and we
get so much like serotonin and dopamine
from it i don't know because it's not i
was like that crazy with my nieces and
nephews cradle cap like
it's like
cradle cap is like it's like a hormone
when new babies and newborns get it you
can have it until you're like three or
four but it's just like dead skin on
your head on your scalp
that's the only thing that'll make me
one of the
look forward to like going home and
picking their cradle cap and my sister
and my mom get so mad at me on other
kids other than my knees but you would
just peel the skin off pick it off yeah
well that makes sense like a maternal
instinct but when it's other people's
babies i'm not related to like if my
it's someone else's baby or my cousin's
baby i'm like that is disgusting get
that away from me i only wanted to do it
i only had this like urge to do it my
direct nieces and nephew like it was
great like it was crazy like i wasn't
allowed to be alone
with them in their heads
because i was like they'd come back and
all their cradle cap would be gone and
my sister would be like they're not
supposed to pick it off and i was like
it's supposed to just fall off
never heard of cradle caps yeah but wait
why why is it why is it all crazy some
hormone like a hormone
from a hat no it's just called cradle
cap because it's all over your head it's
so it's like and they're in a cradle
well no i mean it's like the word
cradle's just such a creepy word
yeah it does like your kids have cradle
cap
no and
it's like a fungus no it's not a fungus
hat it's from it's i think they call it
cradle cap because the top of their head
is resting in your elbow pit when you're
holding them all day breastfeeding okay
i'm just a little distracted with all
this erotic conversation i know it
really it really is you ever looked at
tonsil stone videos
those are disgusting
is this pulling something out of your
tonsils it's these
uh these videos where they push and this
this stuff comes out of your
it's like a tonsils rock it's basically
and it's
it's i have supposed to see is it tonsil
though no it's like all food that got
because you have holes in your tonsils
and so it's all food that got compacted
and calcified and so it's like a stone
of smelly old food
see
mouths are not my favorite yeah okay
mouths are a bummer
yeah i'm gonna send you one of these
videos and you might change your mind
can i tell you the grossest of all the
grossest ones yes spot flies so when i
got
uh my boobs fixed i had um stitches
that were what are the stitches that are
inside dissolvable stitches oh yeah okay
okay
i have dissolvable stitches and as i'm
like
oh this is so gross i have dissolvable
stitches and like i've never had fake
boobs before i've never had like
stitches that were like left in you know
and i'm such a like this thing the thing
in between my boobs that was the pip i
had to get it sewn up no yeah yeah this
was the thing that kept filling up and i
kept squeezing it filling up i went to
dr lancer he said oh it's a pit you have
to laser the shit out of it and then sew
it together and it's a whole thing i
couldn't take a shower for four days or
whatever and so that's fixed but
i always am
plucking my nipple hairs and there are
times that you'll have a little zit on
your nipple you know what i mean like
you'll just i'll just like never oh like
he not on your nipple like kind of i or
like an ingrown hair in a knife you know
like you can squeeze it and then like
sometimes two hairs come out
no feel free to say no no no
no no this is where you abandoned me
this is where you turn on me wow if it's
like a little zit here but on my nipple
on my nipple i'll have like an ingrown
hair and i don't have like
boobs yeah but you have nipple there's
no yeah that's nice
i don't mean that you're booming
and you're squeezing out of you i'm not
saying your tit is a giant pimple
maybe that's why you don't have any
boobs you kept popping up
and so the bottom was the stitches and i
looked down one day at it and there was
like there's a scar or whatever and i
just you know when i see a bump i want
to squeeze right and i see and i start
squeezing
oh god when i tell you
like a
a voluminous amount of viscous
i don't know if it's pus i don't know
what it is but it's like
what pat
i hate to interrupt right now i have to
um i have to swap your card
we've never had this happen we've never
had when is the last time you've ever
need to swap a video card an audio card
right as i'm about to talk about how i
squeeze pus out of my tip this feels
like boundary okay let's talk about
article furniture you guys saw i posted
in my stories the other day grace i've
been trying to order outdoor furniture
and i can't decide that's correct you
have everything's the wrong color it's
the wrong shade it blends in too much
with the trees it doesn't blend in
enough yes it looks like wood it doesn't
look like wood i can't i i know i don't
want to accidentally water my outdoor
furniture because i think it's a tree
and you'll probably do it again it was
cleaning it
but i went on article and i found
three really cute couches i just i had
them vote uh because i couldn't decide
which one because i have those other two
articles i love the they're like
farmhouse navy chairs yeah they're
gorgeous there are two rocking chairs i
had my coffee in those every morning but
i moved those to like a spot where i can
like look out i just need like a giant
sectional thing but article is you guys
know this my favorite furniture store uh
and it's like wildly shockingly fair
the prices because it's 30 off over
traditional retail prices i think they
do it be that's right they're able to
keep their prices low by cutting out the
middleman they physically cut
this guy that's in the middle and then i
was dating him
they sell directly to you no showrooms
no sales people no retail markups so
that's how they save yes it's not like
child labor or something because at
first you're like this is suspiciously
right right right
yes and also i feel like there's stuff
now it's
like we've been working with them for a
minute it's like my exact style like
scandinavian vintage looking really
simple and cool but now there's like
kind of a little more
flair fancy options that on there now
articles offering our listeners fifty
dollars it's the best articles offering
our listeners 52 off your first purchase
of 100 or more article.com whitney and
go to article.com whitney and the
discount will be automatically applied
at checkout that's article.com whitney
to get 50 off your first purchase of 100
or more i feel like you're like a tough
person yeah i feel like you have like
velvet like tough
try shabby chic
you know what i do on my shabby chic
furniture shit your pants
catalina
can i tell you something that's so fun
literally what i did i just put in my
luggage when we were like a full bag i
have a bag of catalina crunch in my
luggage at all times in my backpack and
in my purse it's ollie it's amazing
because it's zero sugar it's keto
friendly and low carb but still
absolutely delicious because most zero
sugar food is not tasty but catalina
crunch nails no i no i it's all i eat
again megan fox
eats it i don't know what else you need
i learned about it but i like the
chocolate and the maple oh yeah that one
this is maple waffle oh yeah i just like
snack on it all day and i feel like
like it's it makes it so that i don't
eat garbage right they have eight crave
worthy flavors to choose from they have
the cinnamon toast the dark chocolate
and creamy chocolate peanut butter um
and if you can't decide what you want to
do there's a variety pack see why
catalina crunch cereal is the fastest
growing cereal brand in america look
it's catalina flour which is pea protein
potato fiber non-gmo corn fiber tapioca
flour oh and then sunflower oil that
makes sense but it's good because it has
some fat in it that's what you want
right that's good and you can just go to
catalinacrunch.com whitney for fifteen
percent off your first order plus free
shipping holy shit iron dot com slash
whitney again that's catalina crunch.com
whitney for 15 off your first order plus
free shipping speaking of um
low sugar burnt pressure
speaking of low carbs and eating cheetos
bur crisis is going to return to the
good for you podcast uh and our live
show we're doing our first live show
i have actually
not been excited about doing something
this much for like a while
too it's on easter
so i feel like everyone's gonna like
want to get away from their parents or
right
and their bullshit chaos like it'll be a
good like you would have seen your
family would have gone horribly south
right um you had to go to church
you have some evening plans you got like
a weird boner in church and you feel
weird about it i don't know you're the
priest
[Music]
[Laughter]
huge demo for this podcast clergy so we
are going to do clergy we are going to
do a live podcast but i am it has to be
like great and like
really risky dangerous and it seemed
like people really did like when i
ruined
basically my entire life and friendship
with jen kramer by
getting blackout drunk on her episode so
i don't know if i i don't want to get
that drunk but we are going to play
strip
truth or dare yeah never have i ever
ever
never strip never have or drink never
drink never have ever we are gonna have
a bowl we're gonna have a couple just a
jar of drugs you know what we're gonna
have a jar of drugs but i feel like
and we're gonna have a piercer we think
yes and so
this is it's not gonna end well not at
all but it will be entertaining
permanent damage done to all of our
lives daddy ford is now a sponsor betty
ford slash whitney get your tickets now
for this live digital experience one
time only go to momenthouse.com good for
you it's april 17th at 6 00 p.m pacific
time and we are gonna have you guys send
some questions that we are going to
answer while inebriated and how are we
going to ask we're going to have them
live yeah we're going to figure that out
so if you are if you get tickets you can
ask questions live through this moment
house thing yes you don't have to send
them in advance yes okay good and we're
going to be feeling vulnerable yeah so
soups vault
and let me just save you the time i'm
still single
emily it has i don't know about emily
live i'm now getting really nervous it's
a lot of it's a lot of winking to camera
like you're like this is why you have to
watch it you're like one celine purse
away from like air gunning to the camera
i love anthony
sorry for all the young people watching
us be so old okay so
we had to just stop for a moment because
pat
uh
uh
quote-unquote
had to change an audio card which is a
fake
for stop talking about popping your
nipples i basically was saying i was
popping puss out of my nipples and pat
all of a sudden to quote change the
audio card
which i've never heard before
but when you don't they
with breast implants don't they put the
nipple back on
you know what's really funny
when i
first got them i had no idea like i got
i was ashamed i was embarrassed i
basically got them because um i had
really bad eating disorders growing up
and my boobs grew in like different
sizes and i had a scoliosis thing so
they were really crooked and so i
basically went in to go just try to get
them evened out
and so i went like i just went to
beverly hills and walked around i was
too embarrassed to ask anyone or like
google it or whatever and i just like
looked around like boobs for like the
boob store yeah yeah
and i swear to god i was on uh um
roxbury or whatever in beverly hills and
then i saw
a door it was a glass door that had like
gold writing on it so it's gold writing
must be fancies must be legitimate and i
feel like i know
that door for sure yes i do for sure
it's like an ornate handle like wooden
old door it's like an old and it's like
smoked glass it looks like an apoca
theory which is like
i've made this mistake you can ask dan
it's not rose apoca ferry no no it's a
apothecary apothecary i've never been
here it's really hard it's hard you know
what here's the deal with apothecaries
i was kicked out of one
for saying it wrong swear to god
kicked out of a
an apothecary
jennifer goodwin's birthday party we go
to ojai valley inn and spa there's an
apothecary
i like mine better mine's buying rolls
off popcorn
berry that's cooler yeah and an open one
i think so too
we sell like chicken pox yeah or like
extractions
who is you know
one of my best friends but also a very
opposite of me uh i may like
like let's like on vacation i'm like
let's go for a hike let's better
ourselves let's let's read more
never go on vacation she's like well
look this is this is a vacation to me as
far as i'm concerned um
and uh
there was a apothecary and we were gonna
go make perfume the problem is i'm just
such a workaholic like overachiever
right my brain goes like let's sell this
let's start a business
i can't just do something for fun and
not try to turn it into a business or
turn it into a like well should we sell
this and donate the proceeds to africa
like it's just like just just put a
bunch of oils in a fucking jar bitch
we're like just it's a birthday party
so we're making perfume
at the apothecary why would you make it
if you're not going to sell it anyways
that's my point what who is this fun for
yes yes i also get money in our business
and also branding it like thinking of
how that should like look and how i also
have very i'm good at this yeah so i
just wash my hands and it smells good in
there like if i feel like i'm good at
something i'm like i should do this for
a living yeah
yeah
i don't want to be good at something
just for no reason what's the point like
i might as well
you know
and so i'm doing this i'm getting really
into it
and
they're having fun which i don't i don't
have fun having fun
i don't have fun having fun oh my god
fun is
work
fun yes i'm you guys are just like
having glass don't want like having a
good time i'm over here building a
business a perfumer just talking and i'm
listening for what the good idea is from
this chat
i'm studying you so in the future when i
play someone who's having fun i'll know
what to do oh my god i'm like they're
that's did dan tell you and i can't
believe he didn't because
he knows i'm
like
i he'll invite me to things to be nice
but like i'm just researching i'm
not gonna go unless i'm doing stuff yes
there it's it is a are you birth order
what's your birth order oh uh i'm i have
an older brother okay interesting um
youngest but usually youngest has to
like fit into an already existing system
and figure out like how do i shapeshift
in order
but i guess i am the youngest if i have
an older brother
so that's what i was thinking about but
um uh
it's just fascinating because
me i just like to be useful or
productive productive if i'm not useful
or productive i just don't know what i'm
doing with myself and i know it that
what i'm saying is i'm not enough i
can't be present i can't be in the
moment i don't i can't receive receive
joy or just
sometimes i can it's a very just the
circumstances have to be perfect and it
probably has to be
functional
filmed yes
oh my god so we do you because i can't
watch any tv that isn't a documentary or
understanding
i only non-fiction yeah i can't read
fiction it's just if i need to research
something for a thing i'm doing um but
yeah
i can't do things for pleasure i don't
get pleasure funny i used to literally
only have sex for exercise
i was like yeah i guess i don't get it
like this isn't pleasurable to me but i
know i'm burning calories so i'll do it
oh yeah like that's how gnarly
like i was for the longest time about
because self-deprivation is something
that it's not something you really
choose
it's just something that like it doesn't
occur to you to enjoy something like i
just that wasn't a big part of my deal
and but i also enjoy
uh the things that i enjoy most people
don't like i love doing chores and
organizing what most people think is
work is my
kink yeah what i find fun
going to a party with a bunch of people
where you have to like make sure they
like you and make sure you kill in the
conversation and you're charming that to
me is not fun that doesn't work work
work and i can do it if it's work that's
what i own
a bookshelf that's fun
so but i'm so i'm a disaster like really
bad but if you open a drawer in my house
it is color-coded alphabetical
everything i don't think you're a
disaster oh i'm really messy don't talk
about my friend like that
look i needed someone to tell me when i
had this negative self-talk which loops
back to beautiful liar look at us
look at the connective tissue the
negative self-talk of i went to my
therapist once and i was like oh because
i'm such an idiot and why did i fucking
text him back and we're just so dumb and
she's like why do you
talk to yourself like that and i was
like oh no it's just like
self-deprecating like it's just like a
joke i'm just being funny yeah and she's
like it's not that funny
oh
oh wow and i was like damn
you're right because when someone else
deprecates in front of you that you
respect and you like you're just like
why are you hurting yourself in front of
me now i have to fight with the i have
to argue with you about your worth yeah
you know what i'm saying and then it
turns into this thing of like if you so
emily if you say you're a disaster
you're telling me i'm bad at hiring
people
oh wow you're telling that now when you
insult yourself around me you're
insulting me and i was like i'm an idiot
so i would i would hire an
idiot
yeah you know what i mean so it turns
into this like mind game of like oh fuck
i can't have low self-esteem without
insulting someone that
i had this thing where this therapist
once told me to
think of myself as younger me and like
as like when i'm a kid and like really
picture that
oh that's really young that's like
right
so the inner child work over here at the
good for you podcast has gone so far as
uh that i have a photo of myself uh in
my actual sonogram that's so weird i had
myself at five years old as my uh
background photo on my cell phone for
like seven years
to be
like yourself well
the way that i was able to sort of like
um kick those eating disorder
uh uh things
is um how would i feed a five-year-old
child that's oh my that's exactly right
how would you take care of this would
you do this to this would you say this
to this woman i forced them to do this
would you not force them it is like if
you really go into it it's a total
paradigm can you believe and not i i've
we forgive others not because they
deserve forgiveness because we deserve
peace i forgive all of our parents they
did the best that came with the tools
they had i mean
remember when
our parents used to make us finish
everything on our plate finish that
glass of milk yeah
what
you want me to deep throat this calm
real quick
like this nipple pass like again
a glass of whole milk like i would sit
there and you would hide your food you
would eat just the the
the
pressure that that we were the love that
we were given that now you look back and
you're like i would never force a child
to
yes or and i wouldn't try to make them
think that like if they're good and
something's good that you'll get candy
if you're good if like putting emotions
with food is something and i think if
you're good you'll get a cookie if
you're just quiet i'll give you candy
yeah
that like currency like food as a reward
yeah
pedophiles were on to something yeah
yeah um but uh i don't know how we got
here
but it's fascinating just that kind of
like
when you look for that like blueprint
yeah that kind of oh it's because i said
i was a disaster right that i was like
and but that is so you because you you
couldn't be less of a dessat i mean you
were 20 minutes early oh today
yes so i'm so you know what you are
people you know what you are
a liar
you're not a disaster but you are a liar
because you just called yourself a
disaster well but like my if you came to
my house i mean you have to i'd have to
create paths i'd have to like it's
what's in the home
[Music]
no no no just like i take off something
and throw it on the ground it's just
like
but it's organized to you yes see yes
that's my thing too like in small ways
like in a drawer all my my underwear my
socks they're all like like
murray condo like yeah
um but the big
and or my lists my lists are very
lists uh redo those little make it look
nice
for to do or because to me my whole deal
is making the list makes me not need the
list yes so to get it out of my head
that's great because it will i'll never
sleep a list is just like taking a shit
yeah it's just i need to put it out
there yes on a piece of paper to get it
out it is if i write it out or make a
list i already got it yes and i don't
have to be afraid that i'll forget it
do you
so i get very
happy when people cancel on me even if
they're people i want to see
because i feel like i've just been
gifted this time that i would never have
given myself
um do you
is that a thing
that
or no i'm like if i want to get someone
a christmas gift i should schedule
dinner with them
on december 23rd yeah at 7 00 p.m
lock it in
and then canceled two hours before yes
that would be the greatest gift i can
give you is like two hours
of free time that you
you didn't feel it because you didn't
feel you had to you had given it to
someone that's exactly how i feel now i
would if someone cancels on me someone i
love yes someone i know married
cancelled when i was home for christmas
and i was like oh what should i get
ready for christmas my mom was like oh
you should just take her out to dinner
and i was like you know what my gift to
whitney's going to be not inviting her
out to dinner
with me like the best thing i could give
her but i gotta put the time away
because if you don't invite her to
dinner then she's gonna fill that well
yeah that's no that's it schedule the
dinner
so that i carve the time out and then
cancel but it has to also be cancelled
too close to the thing for you
another thing or
you can't
know the person you're canceling on if
you're going to give the gift of two
hours yes yes so don't cancel
no don't cancel if it's at seven don't
cancel six cause i've already left right
because you know i remember going on
maybe 20 minutes early yes so just
cancel
the morning of so now i have the evening
free for self-care so i would go so i
would go hey
we're not gonna have dinner tonight
you're just gonna take care of yourself
we're gonna be such a good friend
because
do you like to parallel play this is i
don't know if this is like hancock where
like two superheroes they get together
and it like they weaken
or
what's what's gonna happen like this
could go either way yes i am i do
feel exactly that because i think like
if we hung out together the way that
would probably work best is uh parallel
play or working on something together
like all my friends it sounds terrible
but they're people i work with because i
that's when i'm if we're not going to
work together we're not going to see
each other we're not going to
wow that's my thing
it's just like
which is the easiest way to ruin a
friendship is to start working together
uh you know also which is also fine too
because this friendship could have gone
south for a litany of reasons here's
where i am i move through the world in a
constant state of embarrassment
well like
of everything just in general yeah yeah
just in general like like
self-consciousness i hate when i feel
self-conscious like i and i do a lot but
that's
that's i hate that the most of feeling
like
well like self-conscious like conscious
of myself
it's so weird because there's a
difference between being confident and
being self-conscious like i think a lot
of people think of actors and people
that are forward-facing they're like oh
you're so confident like you're such
high self-esteem because it's like you
know that
that's so funny that's not how it works
like isn't that a wild thing to go like
oh i'm self-conscious yet i'm oddly
confident because i chose a job where
i'm presenting myself to the world that
is so interesting because i've never
really thought of those two things
together but i just think of like an
audition i'm never more
self-conscious i'm like why do i put
myself through why did i become an actor
or what
um but and yet i have put myself in this
position masochist and yes yes yeah and
but then there's also something that
like when it's on it feels fucking great
when it's like chasing that feeling yeah
well it's the same thing of like
athletes it's like you know
uh you know cheerleaders like you know
the vera cheer we talk about this a lot
like the professional
cheerleaders like you practice for a
year
of like hurting yourself and injuring
yourself and it's for
two minutes of adrenaline and glory you
know or like whatever like skiing it's
like you put on the thing and you
and you go up the gondola gondola
for 30 seconds it's like everyone's got
their version of that and i'm able to
see in other people where i'm like why
would you do that that seems like it's
so much pain for such a little
reward but that's also i think what as a
performer
yeah it is like for me it's like when
people like as a stand-up
you know we don't get paid to perform i
get paid to
fly
to
you know be in pre-check to wait in line
to avoid the guy to sit in the plane to
get the whatever strep throat and inhale
your farts to lane like that's i get
paid to travel not to do stand-up yeah
i love traveling though when i'm in the
plane are you afraid of being on a plane
i am so good at plane
at this point
there's never anywhere i feel
more like i get on the plane the minute
it starts to go i'm like not my fault no
matter what happens
out of my hands yeah and i have no fear
of dying
a plane is like
for a control freak i'm self-identifying
is kind of nice because you're like
yeah
like no god grant me this trying to
accept the things i cannot change the
courage to change things i can't and
like wisdom to know the difference it's
just like
for a virgo a flight you're like oh yeah
and i'm needing only you have wi-fi it's
your only day off yeah is when you're on
i mean i still do work yeah but like
because that's wasting a lot of time
well because they just figured it out
with the apple pay and all that kind of
stuff so it's like now that i'm not just
re-entering my credit card 67 times to
boingo what why don't you listen
christ now that they've figured out the
wi-fi situation but it's not it's not
and i also like going uh up and down it
to me
there's nothing more entertaining than
uh
walking up and down on a plane and
seeing what everyone else is watching
and doing god that's sewing i love that
i'm just like you're just going to watch
big bang theory yeah
[Laughter]
while cutting your toenails
not even your cuticles yeah just just
straight up
in those under armour jam jams
with like a kid asleep on your li i'm
just like watching other people live
because on planes people will live as if
they are in their home yes i like
watching people i do it at concerts too
like i don't like i'm the only person
who doesn't like live music i do not do
live music
this is awesome
why would i do that i did it one time
the only time i will see live music if
it is front row with the foo fighters
and i'm in the movie
uh i will do it if it's a box and it's
not a diva thing it's just like i don't
want to be standing or
not you know my thing is live music they
can't see me
they don't even know i'm here
oh that's amazing it's just like what
are you doing this month won't be anyone
my thing is but the audio is so much
better if we just watch
we watch it on spotify on youtube now i
can see your face
i'm a live performer though too so i'm
the first person to be like
oh i'm just going like oh god this ac
right like i'm just worried about the
performer because i know what it takes
to do that yeah yeah and then also
i get so codependent when i go see a
live performer because i'm like
i just want to start being the um uh
the r.a
that i because i see people taking
selfies and being obnoxious i'm like
i become like the
hall monitor yeah yeah i'm yeah
but i also like watching people at
concerts watch the concerts because or
just wha anywhere in the dark where
people think they're alone like on a
plane i start to watch the people
instead of the show
i went and saw an interactive uh
rocky horror picture show
screening
and the screen was in front of me when i
say i was facing the audience
the audience with everyone they've got
their you know because when you do an
interactive like cult classic screening
that people have a bag of all their
stuff and i'm just watching these people
and i'm like i
people say to me all the time like you
can't just stare at people in public
like i will stare at people having
conversations i will listen to their
conversations like nothing is more
entertaining to me than just a random
people at the airport having
conversations that might if you
you know that is my
throne your super power mine would be to
be invisible invisible
so i can yeah here and see but maybe
that's why we don't want to have small
talk i don't want to interact
but i'm very interested like i don't
want us to have to i don't want to have
to engage but i want to
i want to know everything everything
fascinated
we're gonna have some fun together okay
yeah i was like if if this is all true i
feel like i am just what movies formed
you la speed round oh god growing up
would you watch never ending
um okay whoa
what but do you i know it all makes
sense you watched a horse get sucked
into uh
okay that was a trey sinking
to this day a never-ending story a horse
sinking in a fucking mud puddle that was
that was
i used to wear a necklace around my head
to be the prince the child princess with
the pearls the pearl like the little cum
pearl pearl necklace on your forehead
yeah it's such a school it's such a
cumshot when you look back at it well
when you look back at that it's weird
when you watch it as an adult it's about
depression yeah the nothing it's this
kid loses his mom and then goes into
like and then nothing yeah yeah that's a
big one never ending story is a big one
yeah but that one i couldn't really lock
into as much because of the horse yeah
oh my god i was pretty woman i was a
prostitute every year from
until till i left home um but in canada
do we say that no i i miss hooker i miss
hooker
i miss the word hooker i never really
used choker oh really prostitutes i
think now it's like what is it
i think it's a sex worker oh yeah got it
beautiful smart equal what do we call
them though
woman doing the best she can with the
tools she's got you know we call them
smarter than us
in canada though you have to like your
mom's like put your snow suit on under
your costume putting your snowsuit on
under your
hooker slut
whatever things were not supposed why is
halloween by the way the resilience
how
hard we want to be slutty on halloween
is so funny to me because it's october
31st it's so cold and we're still like
you know what
i'm gonna be julia roberts and pretty
woman compeller high water
every year we should all just be
abominable snowmen but we just won't
yeah or like the marshmallow stay puff
guy that is so funny we have to try
extra hard to be slutty because it's so
cold well it's your only chance to do it
without like
you know it's not my fault
it's like outside of planes
[Laughter]
yeah
okay so pretty woman you know that was
initially going to be a drama initially
she died
that's what it was called did you have
you been watching them make the so i'll
watch the making of these
that's all i okay what's the making of
labyrinth is pretty much fine most of my
life
okay
so yeah three thousand dollars that was
so and what was so interesting though is
that she was cast in that and they kept
her for the new one that i think and by
the way the fact that
the america's sweetheart julia roberts
the fact that pretty woman this charming
movie
jason alexander oh yeah what was his
name in seinfeld
george
from seinfeld raped america's sweetheart
yeah and he slap
he was like
he didn't rape her i mean well he didn't
stick the landing yeah
you know but he tried he well he made
going back watching pretty woman now
having
watching anything now going back it's
really fast
it's just for anyone to watch pretty
woman now i don't recommend it because
if you've seen seinfeld and not pretty
woman watching george dancer like it's
just that must be
it's not a comedy anymore if you haven't
seen it if you're seeing it for the
first time oh yeah no no no no traumatic
i remember him being like he was just so
awful in that like in a good way he did
his part amazing actor yeah yeah what
what were the movies that formed you
um labyrinth was big
uh
ruthless people shelley long bette
midler
that was big uh three amigos oh
lots of like silly comedy stuff
coneheads like my dad like my i had an
older brother
and i watched his like leftover movies
oh yeah but in terms of like fantasy
stuff it was really labyrinth oh
oh i remember trains planes and
automobiles oh yeah so all like john
candy she was very big in canada yeah
yeah interesting meatballs yeah that's
big airplane did you watch uh my
so-called life yeah that was big for me
roseanne was the thing that i feel like
that's the last tv show i've watched
that in seinfeld and other than that i
that's why i haven't seen anything
unless i'm auditioning for it yes yes
yeah that's right by the time you became
an actor it was like yeah that was
you can enjoy it the same way yeah yeah
do you listen to music
around your home or in the car
uh in the car in the car i
have to well i don't drive really
so yeah i listen to music i usually say
it's because i get carsick it's mostly
because i don't want to talk
see that's fascinating because i realize
uh uh
people come into my life and they'll be
like there's a
noticeable absence of music oh i don't
like music in a house i like mute i love
music but i have to like uh
if i if music is on i'm listening to it
yes i want it
[Music]
it's not just in the background for
music isn't just in the background you
know what i'm saying because music is so
emotional for me it's like if a song
comes on like whoa shit now i need to
talk about like where you know the song
was written it was in this movie and it
was in this commercial and nobody did
who's the drummer during this was van
halen was before after that like i can't
just enjoy a song playing in the
background like for me music is like an
active thing yeah and people find it so
odd that i don't just have music on all
the time and in the car i'll drive
without music
oh because i need to like think i can't
think and listen to music at the same
time that makes sense to me i can't i
really have a hard time with music on
and people talking
like those two things feel like
one has to go yeah once again um one or
the other but music i do or let's put on
enya if you want to talk we gotta put on
enya buddha khan
and
conversation
not good but then i always make like i
use music as like i make a playlist for
a character yeah it's very like
for a purpose yes and the only time i
don't listen it's not for a purpose is
when i get an uber and i'm just top 50
like yeah we don't talk about bruno
i also if i'm listening to me i'll
listen to the same album for like three
months yeah yeah the same music for like
three months and then i'll move to a new
one i don't like surprises like i don't
want some random playlists where i'm
like this song came out of nowhere yeah
i like to know the song i need to know
what this next song is coming up yeah i
know the whole top 50 right now
like i don't want any curveballs because
music is so emotional to me i don't want
to be just like hanging out with a
friend and like you know
um
jagged little song from rent comes on
and i'm like fuck
yeah it's just like a i have to plan
music because it can it is so impactful
on my mood that i can't just have it be
a random playlist situation yeah that
makes sense and then at my christmas
party remember i missed the entire
christmas party i had at my house
because i was spent 40 minutes looking
for my phone because i made a playlist
of christmas music
and
there's this melissa etheridge cover of
the war is over
by john lennon in yoko ono
which hot take
what i liked his work better after yoko
oh oh oh okay
yoko owner john lennon wrote this song
the war is over happy christmas
after
uh the beatles and melissa etheridge
covered it and remember at my uh
christmas party melissa etheridge walks
in the door
and i think i knew she was coming with
someone that
her wife is a good friend of mine and we
work together
and and i was like oh my god melissa
etheridge is here
her songs on my playlist like i need to
turn it off
bef i need to like get delete it from
the playlist so that i'm not talking to
her and while that's coming on oh my god
it was a stupid like neuroses moment of
like i don't want her to feel awkward
that i'm a fan and that this is my
favorite christmas song
and i don't want to be this dork
so i was like looking for my phone for
40 minutes
remember that it was a great time yeah
it was a great time
and then
and then someone requested a song in my
people-pleasing like um
shit show brain i put it on and then it
went on repeat for 40 minutes so i ended
up playing a rupaul like silly song as a
joke
for 40 minutes that's hilarious but then
um
the
people-pleasing thing i feel like
um
that i am more comfortable
making sure you're all okay you're fine
and that's why i think i like to be
alone so much is because in my mind if
i'm with people then i i'm doing
whatever
to make them
feel
which is by the way some of that like is
you know i'm in
program to try to not be codependent but
but it's like living with someone is
like
it's like you go to make a coffee and
you're like dude
you're there do you want one yeah do you
die you have to consider someone else i
remember this is when allison bree was
on the podcast remember and this is the
an interview that i was so insecure
about but like you know her and um dave
franco i was like you guys live together
when you cross each other in the hallway
like do you
like do you say you have to be like hey
like do you have to talk to each other
all the time like is or
but then it's like
why aren't you saying hi like it's just
it feels like a full-time job to
co-exist with someone in the same space
yeah unless you have there's like i've
maybe it's just one person now but that
i is a person who i can just like
not talk to yes and like that's heaven
someone that you know is self-contained
yeah yeah yeah yeah and knows that i
i just like doing my own thing yep and
and every day is a new day because then
my brain the ocd comes in if i'm like
i'm making coffee it's like do you want
one
and then i go yes you've established a
routine that's why i don't say good
morning like when you every time i make
coffee i have to ask you now i'm setting
it's just this one time i just asked it
and i'm not i now am not
uh uh stuck in a thing where i always
have to ask you yeah you need someone
that's flexible with it yeah that can be
inconsistent and
yes i'm totally inconsistent except for
my very specific routines
but then i also won't
do the like
well i just i don't date anymore but
when i was dating i would never do like
good night or good morning because
that's then now that you're in a
relationship and it's done
that's why i don't date anymore
because it's a hassle nightmare yeah i
am not i have no obligation to be the
person i was yesterday
that's my thing if anyone i'm dating
it's like you have to be okay with me
being a radically different person today
than i was yesterday because i changed
my mind all the time i'm radically
predictable in a lot of ways but i am
also
like
want to be okay with being able to have
an aberration happen and not be um
what's the word uh not loyal to it when
you're um
beholden beholden to like a pattern that
i accidentally established yes that's
over you know that remember i picked you
up from the airport when we first
started dating i'm like i'm never doing
that again yeah but i would feel the
obligation that i would have to keep it
up and then i would rather end the
relationship yeah yeah you're working
and i have to because i know myself that
i wouldn't just be like i'm i'm going to
change my mind i feel bad about changing
my mind with somebody else yeah yeah no
i'm at a place where i'm like i changed
my mind all the time i'm very mercurial
like i have it has to be for fun and for
free and i won't do anything out of
obligation and that's not me being a
bitchy brat
it's me
uh making sure that our relationship
stays good because codependence breeds
resentment if i do this out of
obligation i'll just slowly start to
hate you and now i'm keeping score and
this is toxic yes
did you read that codependence no more
but of course
yeah that of course really because i
didn't understand what codependence was
before i thought it's like i'm not
dependent on anyone
right the inability to tolerate the
discomfort of others
yes or perceive discomfort
yes and
so much so that i think i have the
pendulum has swung to where i'm like i
want to be alone forever and
i'm happy that way because yeah and i
know what you mean because there is this
thing of like
if i'm with someone it's going to be
entrenched yes i'll give all my yes yes
yes yes yes i will get lost in someone
in my identity and such yes that's what
i did and
well yeah there is a happy medium
because it's also when we're in that
state of unrecovered codependence we
gravitate people that are unrecovered
narcissists and need to be rescued like
that will perfectly
they love that whereas now i'm at a
point where
um
i'm so uh
i mean there's a lot to do but in terms
of my recovery like people that would
have been attracted to me 10 years ago
don't even fuck with me now they just
think i'm a bitch yeah because i'm so
hardcore boundary i just have such a
fear okay with them thinking i'm not
gonna fix you i'm not gonna save you i'm
not going to help you like if i meet
someone and they drop something i let
them pick it up oh
oh
that's good
i mean i would
it's yours
nope pretend i don't even pretend i just
go like
oh that's good because i know that if i
do that
now this person is like ah
labyrinth 101 david bowie comes out with
his crystal balls like this is uh you
know so it's like i know that when i
first meet someone the way that i behave
i'm either
attracting someone who is going to
send me back into my childhood role yeah
or not and i'm just gonna like not let
it happen yeah so it's like if someone's
like i'm cold i'm like
cool oh wow that's good i'm not gonna
try to solve this before you try to
solve a problem first make sure it's
your problem it's like because then i'm
that's how i'm able to vet new people
because i can very easily
just get into these like dances with
people that recreate my childhood
circumstances cold oh here's my jacket
oh no come inside somebody needs to turn
no do you go to coda meetings yes okay
yeah therapists once told me i should go
to koto meetings but i never went
they're great but it's yeah you're like
it's hard to get to go to meetings
because you're like i don't want to
bother
and now them like no one in my life
anymore codependents and ottomans
meetings are actually kind of amazing
like
it's there's because there's alano
there's a a aca adult child it's funny
because like in in al-anon meetings you
know the whole thing is like learn how
to like like own your space and take
care of yourself so it's a lot of people
that come in they sit down self-care
they come in 20 minutes late if they
need to but they're going to show up and
they're going to get what they need
because they spent their whole life
living for other people and then you go
to meetings everyone's like sorry i'm so
sorry i'm so sorry it's like no one will
even come in because everyone's so
worried that they're going to be late or
making noise or cause problems like
everyone's walking on eggshell it's just
like it's so to go
between those meetings i mean i've been
going between them for so long it's it's
wild to watch but if you're in a
constant state of like apology
or think that your very existence is
annoying or um
uh
um what's the word um
like if you're just
apologizing for your existence basically
like you're canadian all the time yeah
yeah which is by the way i'm so obsessed
with that ancestral
it makes sense where it comes from if
you go because why because of
homesteading like you are
well i think because there's so little
few
food to go around that you are a problem
if you if you need something that deeply
but you're probably right i always think
of just we're in this shadow of america
a lot when you're in canada and you're
always kind of
self-deprecating and we have breed a lot
of comedians in that way and i think
that comedy is the pride of the
powerless you feel like you wanna yeah
and so i think it's just very canadian
but homesteading that's yeah yeah i mean
it's yeah it's like also this thing of
like i have to make myself really small
so that you'll
help me if i need safety and i need
someone to um you know to be a part of
the pack but you also can just lock your
freaking doors oh yes see i didn't do
that for the longest time we don't lock
our doors yeah that's wild to me yeah
um we have to let emily go i know
i love you i love you too
you guys just witnessed a weird mind
meld i believe this was um what you
would call an enabling session
yes
don't ride elephants
[Music]
four four four
[Applause]